ん
はしごと申します by お墓です
本日は社会をハッキングするということをお話します
これはどういった意味でしょうか
まず3つ3点の説明をさせてください
ウィービングシェイキング dreaming 社会を揺るがす夢を見るそしてつなぐ
ということです
シェイキング優雅数ということはあ
埋まりつつある岩城既存としてある技術政治社会に対して問題を提起して我々の常識を
問うことですこれについては後ほど話します dreaming 夢を見るということ
はもしこうだったらと問いかけることで代替的なコンセプトモデルや戦略をすることを
作ることにあります
ています
夢を集合的に集めるということなのですか
これをラバ夢を共有して共に考えて実現化していくことです
そしてウェービング織り込むつなぐということですがこれは一見反対のものを異なる
ものを
関係のなさそうなものをコンセプト的にアイディア的に折り込んでいくことです
つまりはといい二高あったらいいのに終わっていず
つまり現実的に変えて行くこと
ですでは個々の事例について話していきますシェイキング揺らす貸すことです
これは
bcl でやっているプロジェクト顧問フラワーシリーズプロジェクトです
皆さんの中でこの花をご存知の方はいらっしゃいますか
これは実際遺伝子組み換えの青いカーネーションです
青いカーネーションというのは決してまだ存在したことがありませんというのは
カーネーションには
青い色素を花びらに出すような遺伝子がないからです
ということで別にはという花から青い遺伝子を取り出してがーネーションに入れ込んだ
ものです
これは日本のサントリーというビアビールメーカーさんが開発した手法です
日本に帰国して
初めてこの花を見ましたってすごいなぁでこれは本当に非常に特別な花だと思ったの
です
遺伝子組み換えの花たからというだけではありません
この花は初めて
食物あるいは家畜の飼料以外で初めて遺伝子組み換えされたものです
単に美しさだけのために存在する花です
ということでこの特別な花をありきたりな花に変えたかったのです
これが私のやり方です
これが私のラボです
まあ
このお酒のカップ酒をすべて私は飲んだんですけれどもちろん1番で飲んだわけでは
ありませんよ
このびーん
ワンカップ大関を選んだ理由ですけれどもこの
1カップ押弦大関の裏カバニは市がポエムが書いてあるんですねぇ
ということで今の根底な陽気の中で花を作ったらばいいのではないかと思ったわけです
もちろん
私の実験用にあの
お酒を飲んだ後に再利用できるわけですからそれもいいようなと思いました
ん
でまた赤ちゃんおい育てている友人たちにも声をかけていっ
容器をくれないかしらということで容器を集めました
ということでこれが私のラボです
ホコリやバクテリアから守らなければいけないですのであまり金銭的にも大変でし町東
日本に帰ってきたばかりですしフラットがなかったですのでアパートがなかってですの
で本当にこれは一生ケースを使った安価な自衛権資料です
で
材料あるいはキープというのはまあ diy のストアーやースーパーで買えるような
ものしか使っていません
何をしているかということをお見せしますとこの特別な花のクローンを作っているわけ
です
この特別な花の遺伝子を使ってこれをありきたりにしたいということでたくさんのパク
別な花を
作っていくわけですでこれがタンポポになるような
例えば道端で生えているような本当にありきたりの端にしていこうということでこの
遺伝子組み換えをする時に
精製水と a
んでまぁ電子電子などだとキッチンで使えるようなものそして r 9方アルコール
そして bleach
あの台所用のブリーチ箋調剤の頭使います漂白剤を使います
でこれは世界中にどこでも使える
見つけられるようなものです
で先ほどの大関カップもそして赤ちゃん用の f
ご飯が入っている便というも世界中どういうわけか分からないんですけれども世界中
企画がだいたい標準にあります
ということで材料も容器も世界中どこにでも new 周できます
2013年
これはオーストリアのアルスエレクトロニカあるセンターでの写真ですがともかくその
容器の企画が世界中同じそして
安価でこちらを作り直せるという事ですので
官邸の主府子どもたちのためにワークショップを開いていました
彼らの方が私よりも
うまくできたりも致しますそしてこれが成長させた黒んです他の他国に行った時に
抱っこから招へいを受けるわけですあなたのフラワーと一緒に何かプロジェクトをやっ
てもいいですかと言われます
でみんなに聞かれるんですがこれは日本でも作るんですかと言われていえコロンビアで
やるんですよと言いますなぜと聞かれて
まあ土壌的環境があるカラーというふうに答えます
自分自身で行ってみてこれは青じゃなく紫で
に見えますけれども本当に家でこれができる
いうことを実証していきたいというわけですこのプロジェクト日常系金を揺るがすこと
の好例です
ここから法的な倫理的な疑問が生まれることで既存の製品をハッキングしていきます
というのはこれはいえでクローンやコピーを作っていくわけですからここはグレー
ゾーンになるわ
です
この皆様はガーデニングをされますかおじい様おばあ様が
例えば企業を選定したものをそれを水につけてそうすると根が生えて
まあ大きくなると基本的に私がやっているところもオーナー子なんですけれども
グレーゾーンにあります
こういったやり方で問題提起をしています
でこれはまあ法律的なところも関わってきます
誰にもこれが法律的に広報なのか良い方なのか分からないところですでは次のつなぐ
織り込む
ウィービングといったところに話を移しますこれは象徴的につなぐ織り込むことか
なん
実際に
現実化をしていくことです
まあ x 軸 y 軸の戦後折り込んでいくわけですけれども
違うアイディア違うコンセプト織物のように繋いでいきます
ということで私の他のアートワークとやや趣の違うものを実例として挙げてみます
去年の5月にグーグル a テープという新しいプロジェクト project じゃあ
カールというものを公表しました
プロジェクトちゃっカールというのはスマートテキスタイルのプロジェクトで高伝導性
の糸を使っています
この1頭によってジェスチャーやセンシングインター楽旅インクインタラクティブ生徒
達性能を組み込んでいきます
でもこれは標準的な産業用の汎用
織り機でも使えます
でこのテキスタイルの上で体を受ける動かすと布の方が私の指の動きを感知して何がし
たいかを知ります本当にそうできるのです様々なサンプルをメール in japan
として作りました
あーでこのテキスタイルをサヴィルロウというシーン
に洗脳テイラーさあに持って行きましたサビルロウをご存知の方はいらっしゃいますか
サビルロウというのは実際ロンドンにある道の名前で指定
そこには200年以上の歴史のあるしたティアさんがあります
このテイラーさんにしたティア3に
このテキスタイルでジャケットをつくってくださいとお願いしました
でしたてあの方ではこの繊維の持っている
エレクトロニクス製などについては何も知らなくてもジャケットができたわけです
実際この布は普通の布と何ら変わりがありません
なのでこの仕立て屋さんにジャケットを作っていただいてモーバイル4にこれを繋いだ
時
スワイプを布部でしたらば携帯がつながりました
でこのしたティアさんはびっくりしたわけですねなんとこんなことが起きるなんてと
驚きました
このジャケットは実際はキャンバス地白いキャンバス地で作っていますというのは
プロジェクト者カールというのはクリエイターにとって白いキャンパスだという風に
とらえているからです
様々な可能性があるわけで
皆さんのクリエイティビティをここに反映できるということを考えたわけです
で皆さん私のようなアーティストがこのような大会社と組んでこういったプロセット
するのはなぜかと思うかもしれません
まあありがとうございますそういう自問自答してしまいました
でもウィービングシェイキング dreaming
オリコンこと揺らがすことそして夢を見ること
で私たちというのは
フル私たちというのは新しいコンセプトを織り込んで
業界を揺るがしてそれらを実現化していくことを目指しています
そして
この技術を持って次はどうなっていくのかというのを夢見ているわけです
というわけで次に dreaming 夢絵が出てきます
では10年以上前に私が夢見始めた
もう一つのプロジェクトのお話をさせてくださいバイオプレゼンスというプロジェクト
です
で
どんどん生命体も dn dna の良いおい今日は変化をしています違うのです
まあフグでもラットでも人間でも ta dna を持っているんですけれども
でもその dna の量というのはその生物体の大きさに比例しません
て私たちの方では皆さんの dna を撮ってそれを機に埋め込むことということを
考えました
で埋め込むことによってきの表現型は変更されません
でこれは普通の道端で見られるような木です
出来は実際
皆さんの dna を体内に持つことになります
ということで例えばなくなった愛する家族の方々愛する方々の dna を持った秋を
保つことができるのです
ですので
例えば50年後の先の世界に私の
そう孫の孫がもしかしたらば
いろいろなことをあなたに伝えてくれるかもしれません
これはまあ聞いをハグしている人の写真ですけれども
例えばこれは人によっては生きたメモリアル
遺伝子組み換えのぼ姫という人もいますただ私のこういった記念碑の考え方について一
つの問題があります
これはグラニースミスという欧米瀕死の栽培
リンゴ品種ですグラニースミスこれはまあもし
そしてベジタリアンにとってはカニバリズムになってしまうのかもしれません
昔単なる夢であったものが今や実現可能です
で10年工所で前には技術的には不可能なことでありました
でもこうした生きた記念碑をつける作ることが可能になりました
というのはバイオテクノロジーが発達し価格も劇的に下がりこれが可能となってまいり
ました
ということでこれを実現可能にすべ
串ごとをしていることを公表できているのはうれしいことです
なので決して揺らぐのもつなぐのもそして夢を見るのをやめてはいけません
友人の条例ビスはこのように言いますバイオテクノロジーには悪夢がたくさんあります
でも夢は現実化するものですなのであれば誰かが良い夢を
いなければなりませんということで皆さん良い夢を見ようではありませんか
ありがとうございます